the guys in the uk better than the us
my experience i've only
i've really only gone on dates with one
other guy from the uk
and he did not oh my gosh i need to i'm
gonna tell this story i'm live okay guys
so
right after i got out of my last
relationship okay
i me
i well okay me and my last boyfriend
broke up a couple times throughout the
year
okay like on and off on and off one time
we broke up was for about like three
weeks i would say right before i came
here because he was like i don't want to
do distance i said okay
during this time i met a guy off of
hinge from the uk
i liked him whatever you know but we we
kind of had like a connection but then
when my boyfriend wanted to get back
together i just ghosted him for like
three months okay
you know didn't talk to him then me and
my boyfriend break up again
in
i don't know like december and like a
couple months later and i'm like hey are
you still single by chance you know
i liked him you know but i didn't know
him well enough to like whatever
anyways this man
starts taking me on dates it's like
going well okay
and i like him whatever
but he's like super like he comes down
so strong and i've never i'm like not
used to like
guys being in love with me that fast
well just like like oh i want to date
you this is where like i see where it's
going i'm very marriage-minded i'm like
okay like
cool you know like that's kind of what
i'm looking for but it just makes you
wonder like are you doing this to every
[ __ ] you're like are you doing this to
every [ __ ] and i'm like there has to be
a catch right because he's super wealthy
right super like so i mean like is he
lying about the wealth whatever like
there must be a catch he's too perfect
he's like
you know he's not like hot but he's cute
enough tall enough right taller than me
right has a lot of money right like
super successful
um
and and he he's um
and he's like cool you know super
helpful super nice i'm like what is the
catch and about a couple dates in this
man tells me okay
i
have two kids
and two that i returned
he didn't say returned but this didn't
tell you this part bro bro okay okay bro
bro bro no
no no so he what he does okay let me let
me tell you
bro bro you don't even understand no no
no no no
it's never enough but i don't what do
you no it's like there had to be a catch
if that was it but i was like what is
the catch
i
i don't i don't have kids i don't feel
like i should have to date somebody with
children like i don't know what that's
not what you're no no i don't like
that's just i would take a guy with less
money less everything no kisses if you
are a man with kids
disclose that information before the
date before we don't want to be
a lot of us we don't want to be stepmoms
and if you think oh well she's going to
fall in love with me and want to be like
us no that's not how no that's
information you just closed before
bro
bro
okay okay okay let me just say this
unless you're just looking to like [ __ ]
her and never speak to her again which i
understand i understand i didn't like
but like other than that
bro
and like he was so intentional with
everything so it wasn't like we were
just trying to hook up like he was very
much like i want to date you you know
and
and he was like he watched
this is part of the story i'm gonna tell
you
okay so
so
i
he we're having a movie night right at
my apartment and he puts on the holiday
okay now okay do you remember the scene
in the movie
yes where where the the man the man um
talks about
how
the man talks about how um
like he has kids like he's on the phone
outside and she's like that's weird and
she's like who are you talking to yeah
and cameron diaz and he's like oh i have
two daughters
and she's like mad yeah and he looks at
me and he says would you be mad if that
happened and i'm like
yeah
like i would absolutely i would be
pissed
a [ __ ] to watch holiday in his bed
would you be good and they want you to
be closer to the mic just a little bit
is this what you want
[Laughter]
no okay i don't i don't know okay but
okay at this point guys at this point
this man is watching my dogs i'm going
back to the u.s and he's watching my dog
for three weeks while i go back
up
and so i'm like this is a bombshell he
drops this bomb okay and not only did he
have two kids he had two kids that he
adopted
and sent back
that stayed with him for like three or
four years him and this girl broke up
and they sent them
back you know what
it's not funny it's not funny at all bro
like
people really like blow my mind like
that's [ __ ] up like how do you get a
pro okay how do you get approved for
children
i don't i don't know how it works i
can't speak
uh i don't mind blowing
i don't know what was going on i know
about the two the two other children
part
um
i didn't tell you that oh my gosh so
then like and i kind of liked him you
know like i
i never like did anything with him you
know what i mean yeah and like like
enough i like them enough to like you
know but we'd only known each other for
a little bit but then you drop this bomb
on me i'm going back to the u.s like the
next day
and
on top of that
like
oh my god and on top of that like
you're watching my dog for two weeks
which he offered which i wouldn't have
like accepted it
if i knew it was like you didn't know
anyone else out here and who else was
going to watch what i would i'm i'm
resourceful i would have figured it out
if he didn't drop this bomb on me the
date like it was like a day or two
before i'm supposed to leave and i'm
just like
oh my god this is too much one it was
already moving like way faster than i
wanted it to right
oh my god
that was
no wait okay can i just say like when
she first told me that she was gonna uh
go on a date with this guy i was like
make sure he's not a murderer bro
yeah i
i mean he wasn't a murderer but i
i could not the second and when i broke
i broke it off with him like
because i had to i had to think about it
like at first i'm a thinker so i was
like i'm gonna think about this over
break after so i get my dog back um
and
i'm like look
i
so i break it off with him right
and this man like is not leaving my
apartment like he i'm like okay i'm
gonna order like pizza now he's just
like and i think he's mad because maybe
like he never slept with me
you know so maybe he's like i put all
this like time and energy into this girl
okay yeah
and like maybe he's like hoping i'm like
oh no like
oh no the door like
oh no like
the door is the door like and he's just
like sitting there and i'm like
like i'm like too nice to the point
where i'm just like
i swear to god you stayed for like an
hour and a half
and i'm just like a knife would get
pulled out at that point if it were me
and you know how it is like when you
don't know someone well and you're a
girl and something gets weird like your
mind is like oh my god oh my god like is
anything gonna nothing happened but i
mean like i feel personally like i'm
very possessive of my space like my home
like that's my safe space like
so i feel like at that point i would be
like
yelling screaming get the [ __ ] out like
freaking out like you know you don't
want to like provoke why date a guy with
kids i didn't know
like if i knew he had kids like the
first date i wouldn't have had gone on a
second date with him i had a similar
situation like i was with a guy for
almost over a year and i found out that
he had a
child in chicago my older sister she
dated a guy
they were living together they were like
practically engaged he was about to
propose to her she gave up playing
professional volleyball overseas
she and she this my sister was a amazing
volleyball player like i'm talking
freshman of the year at washington state
played in hawaii your little sister my
older sister your older sister okay not
blood related but my older son yeah
played in hawaii and then also played at
idaho gave up playing professional
volleyball for this guy
and
he had two children also in chicago
yeah
i men are this is the second time i've
been bamboozled with children okay the
first time the first time i was
bamboozled with kids bro the first time
i stayed i was very embarrassing i like
i should not have you told me such a
good sob story
oh my gosh
the first time the first time i was i'm
like i'm just tired just tell me if you
have children up front
kids
no it's not like you learned his lesson
with the next [ __ ] that's all i have to
say
that's all i have to say
not naming names oh my god no no
oh my god no the first um
the first the first guy
i'm not gonna name names but the first
guy that bamboozled me with children i
asked him the day the night i met him
she was you know a little bit more
well-known i'm like do you do you have a
daughter
and like at that point
he's like no no i don't i'm like oh okay
i thought i saw something online that
you did but maybe i did you know
sorry
look at even your girl gets bamboozled
sometimes
anyways i just thought that no meant no
like i don't i didn't know it meant yet
no means no
that's what that's what i thought
as well as what as one shot
anyways so what did i do
i i'm like alright cool whatever i keep
like hanging out with him getting to
know him better
and
my
like we kind of stopped talking for a
second and my friend
that was a dude like we hung out and
we're like no he has kids and i'm like
i'm like okay does he but whatever like
we kind of like fizzled out for a second
so i was like okay whatever whatever
um then then i'm like does he and i
looked it online
and then like i talked to him again
right i'm like do you do you have
children there's this article that says
you have kids
and he's like
no
i don't
and i'm like
okay well why would that doesn't make
sense like what no i'm kind of gullible
like let's let's just like i'm very
global
yeah no i'm so global and so then he's
like
um
no like they just um it's like my nieces
and nephews they just assumed it was my
kids but like some some something that
made sense to me at the time yeah i was
like oh
so he lied yeah
lovely
the [ __ ]
so then
then i tell my friend emily this and my
friend emily she's not
she's like you like if i told you that
you would be like
like you would be searching the internet
for something right
as
some girls
[Music]
you know most people i know tell the
truth about their children you know
that's your prerogative that's that's
you know that's your experience in
life look you asked if he had a daughter
he never said anything about sons it
turns out he had both actually
but
anyways so he um
[Music]
anyway so my so my friend um so it sends
me a screenshot of a picture of him
holding the kid right after it was born
saying like when you like something but
you would dad now
and so i just sent him this screenshot
i'm like sir
sir
probably the only photo he has with
these children like sorry to say i don't
like it i'm sorry i don't know i don't
know what i don't know what happened
with that then he gave me the sob story
oh my gosh
wait
wait wait pearl you have kids dude guy
jenny jedi hand wave i do not have
children pearl you do not have children